als junger männer herzlich willkommen
die heute wieder weiter neuen episode
reagiert auf
die betten
das erste video das ich mir anschaue
welche frauen oder falsche buchungen
kommen luca vielleicht sind das nächste
video ja besser was denkt ihr euch dabei
wenn ich mir sowas schickt erst springt
ein junge auf eine matratze und jetzt
läuft eine junge über eine hecke
wirklich freunde reagiert jetzt qualität
großgeschrieben was ist eine blondine
zwischen juli und luca na da haben wir
es doch endlich mal ein witz hier und
ein bisschen unterhaltung am start also
okay was ist eine blondine zwischen
schule und mir ich hab keine ahnung aber
du wirst es mir jetzt gleich sagen nicht
die dümmste sie mich verarschen
[Musik]
was war das denn für ein video das wird
gerade auf meinem zweiten kanal
hochgeladen ist wie die offenen kanal
das ist verlinkte der beschreibungen
sind da würde ich ja direkt mal drauf
klicken
[Musik]
ja danke für deine proben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wirklich ich frage mich bei euch
wirklich gar nichts mehr das macht eine
blondine in der wüste keine ahnung
vielleicht nicht die dümmste sei luca
und julia auch da sind staus sorgen okay
war wirklich eng für den plötzlich so
von mir den wind der wort autos für
friedrich
[Musik]
eure kreativität lässt wirklich kein
freiraum nach oben
[Musik]
zu dem video muss ich mal wirklich allen
hundebesitzern unter euch eine frage
stellen und zwar sind hunde wirklich so
dass sie sich denken oh da ist ja was an
meinem körper da laufe ich jetzt mal die
ganze zeit im kreis rum ich mein ich
weiß mir ja auch nicht immer
also ja okay dass wir ja lassen wir das
thema ich frage mich gerade noch ob
wirklich runde so dumm sein dass sie
sich denken hey da ist er was einmal im
körper ich weiß dass man rein und dann
bekomme ich so ein video also wirklich
freunde eure dummheit enttäuscht mich
nie
geil digger freundlich echt mega jetzt
fast sicher der videospiel flugzeug
erfolgreich gelandet wahnsinnige haare
mittlerweile bin ich mit den
einwendungen wirklich an so einem punkt
wo ich mich gar nichts mehr frage
ich frag mich nichts mehr
[Musik]
komm mach einfach spiele einfach weiter
ab jetzt
hey was sind denn meine zuschauer für
komische menschen
das kannst du doch echt nicht das ist
auch wirklich und luca ich wollte nun
mal sagen
wichtig hierbei geschadet
und jetzt wird auch mein logo auf mit
stofftier geklebt und mit einem
bleistift in das logo rainer und also
wirklich wahnsinnig kreativität ist mal
wieder aber auf dem mond angekommen
geheißen teigwaren teigwaren weil sie
mal teigwaren waren weil sie mal
teigwaren willst du mich komme nicht ob
wird das ist eine berechtigte frage wie
heißt und hamburg mit als guten hsv
level
wieder auf dem erdkern
er kann nicht auch das wasser komplett
an dem ich das heute wird jetzt
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch diese folge luca
reagiert gefallen hat dann das unbedingt
einen daumen hoch unter dem video werden
schickt mir eure dummen videos an diese
e mail adresse hier videos and laser
do.com steckt außerdem war die video
beschreibung hier unter dem video hier
ab denn dort habe ich euch ein video
verlinkt was sich soeben auf meinem 2
kanal hochgeladen habe und zwar ein
video das ihr an eure whatsapp gruppe
senden soll so schaut gerne beim
zweikanal namens luke ruf vorbei und
abonniert main kanal falls sie noch kein
teil der luchs usaid von meiner
community ist kostenlos und verpasst
keine videos mehr aber jetzt kann das
aber drauf
[Musik]